grazie a tutti per la presenza la mia
presenza qui desiderio di condivisione
condivisione di una attività educativa
che una proposta educativa che da
qualche anno stiamo portando avanti
educatori di diverse sensibilita culture
e religioni accomunati attorno alla
sfida della globalizzazione quindi del
fatto che ciò che era lontano adesso era
vicino ciò che è diverso è diventato
quotidiano allora come vedete dall'altra
la slide noi abbiamo puntato la nostra
proposta è costruito la nostra proposta
educativa attorno al termine sinderesi
che come voi sapete significa capati
capacità di giudizio capacità di
valutazione
ognuno di noi ha poco tempo quella è una
vecchia immagine di una meridiana di
montagnano mentre l'uomo il sole l'ombra
del sole watt e poi torna noi abbiamo 80
e più primaverili e non di più e in
questa primavera e che il buon dio ci ha
dato
siamo chiamati a contribuire a portare
il nostro contributo nel mondo come
diceva shakespeare ognuno deve fare il
suo verso e nella maniera più positiva
possibile
bene questo noi l'abbiamo concepito come
una sinergia per costruire insieme una
capacità valutativa della realtà una
capacità quindi di giudizio maturo
critico
infatti come trovate scritto qui
sinderesi intende qualificarsi
attraverso itinerari formativi ove
giovani uomini e donne siano stimolati
ad elaborare un proprio giudizio sulla
realtà maturo e competente
e così contribuire possibilmente insieme
alla cura della casa comune con passione
generosità onestà e credibilità ecco è
una sfida che abbiamo come dicevo prima
deciso di compiere insieme perché
riguarda l'uomo come tale al di là delle
diverse appartenenze e ciascuno di noi
lecitamente può avere noi crediamo che
esiste uno zoccolo duro comune uno
zoccolo di fondo un fondamento
stante il quale c'è l'uomo e quando
questo non c'è più
l'uomo sparisce scompare allora quali
sono gli itinerari che noi proponiamo
come vedete qua sono tre direttrici di
impegno nell'attività di sinderesi che
poi si
esemplificano in una serie di iniziative
di scuole di formazione
la prima attività vedete è la formazione
alla solidarietà verso chi soffre ed è
più sfortunato crescere e diventare
uomini oggi significa anzitutto rendersi
conto delle fortune che abbiamo
incominciare a guardare anzi non sa a
chi si trova anche in situazioni di
sofferenza e quindi questo fa aiuta
ciascuno anzitutto a valorizzare ciò che
ha ricevuto che ha responsabilità io
posso io sono chiamato a condivide a
dare una mano non tanto a dare invece
diceva un vecchio un vecchio proverbio
cinese ma insegnare a pescara questo è
lo stile con cui insegniamo a stare con
chi ha bisogno
una seconda direttrice e come vedete la
formazione alla convivenza e al dialogo
tra culture e religioni diverse
questo crediamo che sia altre
altrettanto un punto fondamentale perché
l'attenzione
a ciò che è diverso da noi
ma ciò che viene da formazioni culture e
religioni altre non deve essere
percepito come una minaccia ma come una
risorsa e questo è possibile soltanto
imparando a conoscere ad ascoltare a
condividere e background dell'art
abbiamo anche qui diversi itinerari di
formazione tra cui alcuni corsi che
facciamo anche alla luiss dove mettiamo
a disposizione degli studenti la
possibilità di incontrare esperti
provenienti dalle grandi religioni del
mondo e questa è una grande sorpresa
perché perché ciò che sembrava diverso
lontano in qualche modo minaccioso
in realtà si rivela come una uno stimolo
alla nostra crescita personale alla
nostra rivalutazione di ciò che è
importante nella nostra vita a una
purificazione dei nostri assoluti la
terza
direzione è la formazione alla
cittadinanza attiva e responsabile
questo è indirizzato tutta una serie di
scuole cominciare da scuola sinderesi
all'università gregoriana poi a scuole
nelle secondarie su nelle secondarie
delle scuole secondarie dove poniamo
ogni volta nello stile di fondazione
scendere se anche qui tematiche sfide
sociali contemporanee affrontate nel
dialogo con esperti con esperti senso
generale del fenomeno poi dove facciamo
nelle scuole territoriali che abbiamo
sempre esperti territoriali cioè
facciamo vedere come una conoscenza
critica poi si esercita sul territorio
sul concreto sul contesto geografico
regionale provinciale in cui quella
sfida si pone e da ultimo concludiamo
sempre anche qua con un confronto
interculturale e interreligioso per
sentire ad esempio come una cultura
islamica oppure un approccio dalla della
tradizione ebraica oppure dalla
tradizione indù oppure dal buddismo dal
cristianesimo stesso o anche da chi non
ha religione
affronta e pone domande suggerimenti
indicazioni
ecco come tutti vi rendete conto
queste tre direttive sono accomunate da
una un punto essenziale la dialogicità
per noi affrontare la globalizzazione
significa non porsi in un atteggiamento
conflittuale ma dialogico di incontro di
ascolto conoscenza e quindi affrontare
l'altro ecco cosa significa affrontare
l'altra per affrontare l'altro noi
abbiamo scelto la l'icona biblica di
giacobbe voi ricorderete tutti è una
storia ce ne genesi giacobbe è una
figura particolare perché nasce in
qualche modo svantaggiato e il secondo
sono due gemelli giacobbe ed esausti di
isacco e di rebecca giacobbe nasce
svantaggiato perché il secondo ma già il
nome giacobbe significa colui che
soppianta esce con la mano sul calcagno
del fratello passerà la vita a
soppiantare il fratello giacobbe e
modernissimo perché è un individuo che
si deve fare da solo e si fa da solo in
qualche modo sottrae al fratello la
primogenitura sottrae la benedizione
quindi deve scappare farsi una vita
altrove
e anche lì a successo alla fine sposa
riesce a sposare la donna che ama riesce
a costruirsi un mondo una diciamo così
una professione è successo ma prima o
poi anche lui deve fare i conti con se
stesso perché perché è chiamato a
tornare alle sue radici a tornare alle
sue radici significa incontrarsi con suo
fratello giacobbe che ha passato tutta
la vita a ingannare l'altro ha in
qualche modo scatta violare per trovare
una soluzione di ripiego arriva un certo
punto che l'altro lo deve guardare in
faccia e la notte prima dell'incontro
con suo fratello che si può rivelare un
disastro come spesso accade nella vita
degli uomini quando devo veramente
incontrare l'altro e non più schivarlo
nella notte prima poi ricordate questo
episodio sul fiume dello yabboq giacobbe
passato tutta la notte a lottare con un
personaggio misterioso chi è questo mi
son al personaggio misterioso è un
angelo ed io nella l'incontro con gli
amici ebrei nell'esegesi di rabbini che
ho imparato che una delle
interpretazioni possibili e che questo
personaggio misterioso con cui giacobbe
lotta tutta la notte
non è altro che se stesso quell'altro
che sta dentro di sé quella parte di
ciascuno di noi sa è che noi non
vogliamo guardare che non vogliamo
accettare quella parte che facciamo più
fatica a riconoscere ebbene lotta tutta
la notte ha il coraggio di guardare e
proprio perché ha il coraggio di
affrontare questa parte di sé che gli dà
fastidio che ha cercato di ignorare fino
al giorno prima
giacobbe riceve la benedizione è bello
questo chi ha il coraggio di fare i
conti seriamente con se stesso con
l'altro che è dentro di sé tiene bene
viene benedetto ma una una benedizione
di questo tipo
lascia anche una ferita perché non si
passa indenni quando noi facciamo i
conti veramente con noi stessi ci resta
un segno la storia di giacobbe dice che
già poco da quella giornata viene ferito
all'anca che restando in qualche modo
claudicante non riesce più a scajolani e
claudicante ma è benedetto e addirittura
gli si cambia il nome dice io ti
benedico e ti chiamerai israele
anche qui cosa significa colui che ha
combattuto con il mistero colui che ha
combattuto con il mistero di secolo che
hanno combattuto con l'altro di sé con
lui che ha combattuto con il mistero di
dio colui che ha avuto il coraggio di
guardare in faccia
ebbene israele e un nome collettivo
israele sappiamo ancora oggi è il nome
con cui si riconoscono gli ebrei è un
noi è bello pensare che giacobbe proprio
perché ha avuto il coraggio di
incontrare l'altro da sé riesce a
diventare principio di un noi diventa
secondo è infatti il giorno dopo
voi sapete che la storia biblica
continua con giacobbe che incontra esaù
e per la prima volta fa la pace
dialoga si intende i due fratelli
avranno poi un destino diverso una
strada diversa
ognuno avrà un cammino proprio non
vengono sommati non vengono inglobati
non vengono in qualche modo annichiliti
azzerati
no ognuno rimane se stesso ma in pace
con l'altro in un clima di comunione
ecco questo è l'icona di sintesi sintesi
vuole educare attraverso i suoi cammini
a fare i conti profondamente con se
stessi perché solo chi ha il coraggio di
incontrarsi in profondità e di accettare
anche le parti più misteriose di sé
scopre che proprio queste anziché essere
il nostro limite sono la nostra risorsa
ciò che sembrava il nostro nemico è in
realtà la nostra fecondità e proprio per
questo affrontando l'altro che c'è in
noi noi riusciamo ancora una volta ad
incontrare gli altri quelli più
sfortunati gli altri che hanno una
diversa cultura religione e tradizione
pensiero gli altri che come noi sono
chiamati a costruire il bene comune
una terra atti giusta più
degna di essere vissuta più luogo della
convivenza e della gioia e non il luogo
della competizione e del conflitto che
genera paura morte aggressività ecco
questo è diciamo la filosofia di fondo
che guida il criterio di singers
affrontare l'altro che sta dentro di noi
è la condizione che l'incontro con
l'altro ci chiede tutte le volte e se io
ho problemi con gli altri è perché in
fondo in fondo non sono stato capace di
affrontare fino in fondo è di pacificare
di generare gli itinerari di comunione
dentro me stesso ecco perché l'altro è
una continuo richiamo è una continua
risorsa l'altro così come con la sua
diversità con i suoi modi di pensiero
con i suoi itinerari ecco comprendiamo
tutti come questo sia un cambio di
registro idoneo a far incontrare tutti
non
in un senso generico buonismo ma nel
desiderio di valorizzare lo specifico di
ciascuno perché ciascuno di noi è un
dono veramente per l'altro nella misura
in cui la reciprocità diventa la legge
tramite quale si riconosce mutuamente la
possibilità di contribuire alla
costruzione insieme
e dunque ecco che questi itinerari che
noi proponiamo dentro queste tre
direttrici vengono percorsi da ragazzi
da giovani da adulti di diversa
nazionalità confessione religiosa
cultura e questo li arricchisce e molto
bello che ad esempio questa corso che
noi teniamo in luis le iscrizioni
arrivano da tutto il mondo e ad esempio
l'itinerario che facciamo in gregoriana
è aperto a 182 nazioni
insomma una sfida per l'uomo di oggi
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]